[Musique]
bonjour vous asseoir
on montre robuste que les projets toile
quand il dit non c'est mme diop
ah la la
c'est des films de bord qui colle avec
la réalité mais des films dans lequel ya
un certain merveilleux
mais
qui est la belle inconnue
la femme en bleu seul à sa taille
une géante américaine
[Musique]
merci bonsoir et bienvenue
[Applaudissements]
sa petite nika l'influencé nicolas
pouhair hisse au
procès la journée 1 2 par 4 qui tease
ralentir
on attend toujours le meilleur de soi
même et des autres
on est toujours déçu n'est ce pas
et on n'est parfait c'est ça c'est
naturel c'est la vie
speak white
de westminster
[Musique]
mon
jean pierre reid
cb
[Musique]
le bon
monchy
en vain
[Musique]
le cpo murray n'est à mourir et je pense
que vous avez étudié en
campagne et amateurs mes amis
non
nous deux
non les hommes du monde
mais on va plus
le
mon
à partir du moment où on est capable de
savoir d'où l'on vient on est capable de
se voir beaucoup
les mots avait pour moi une énorme
importance la sonorité ces mots là me
plaisait
dans ma vie j'ai rencontré tel match
elle
chaque personne
allez chine
[Musique]